[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera sono una biologa
faccio ricerca quindi la mia attività e
fare esperimenti e questa sera voglio
iniziare con un esperimento con voi a
breve comparirà un immagine alle mie
spalle che vi chiedo di riconoscere
quindi un esperimento di riconoscimento
l'esito dell'esperimento lo sapremo
subito
chiedo scusa a priori se qualcuno
troverà l'immagine un po
pesante un po forte ed è un'immagine che
spero non vada ad urtare la sensibilità
di nessuno di voi vi chiedo quindi di
fare un respiro profondo
pronti
direi che l'esperimento è riuscito
ne ero certo
quello che voi vedete ovviamente
capitano uncino e come ero certa che
tutti voi spero tutti lo abbiate
riconosciuto sono anche certa che
nessuno di voi sa perché nel mondo della
ricerca nel settore nel quale io mi
occupo capitan uncino considerato un
genio
un genio perché ha fatto una scoperta e
ha inventato uno strumento che ha
rivoluzionato la ricerca
capitan uncino infatti ha inventato
l'uncino
ora vorrei ancora la vostra attenzione
su questo splendido dispositivo medico
osservatelo bene da vicino non c'è mezza
macchia di ruggine
eppure è trattato malissimo è nelle
condizioni climatiche peggiori acqua
salmastra caldo nebbia sicuramente sarà
contatto con alcol so che era un po
alcolizzato di rum sangue umano e no
eppure sempre lì splendido splendente e
assolutamente ergonomico capitan uncino
lo utilizzava per fare un sacco di cose
uccidere governare la nave aprire botti
pettinarsi e poi
non costava molto sappiamo che i pirati
erano un po taccagni ma soprattutto non
gli dava allergia
credo che nessuno di noi abbia ricordo
di un capitan uncino che si gratta un
braccio che sia pieno di pustole quindi
era assolutamente eccezionale capitan
uncino quindi pensate all'attività di
ricerca che ha fatto so che in questo
momento sembra più mastrota che faccia
una televendita di materassi ma io non
voglio vendervi nessun uncino futuro
vorrei la vostra attenzione
sull'attività di ricerca che ha fatto
capitan uncino ha cercato materiale
economico che
funzionasse che non si arrugginisce che
fosse ergonomico perché doveva essere
plastico utilizzabile per un sacco di
funzioni pensate a quanti altri pirati
ha aiutato capitan uncino quindi di
fatto capitan uncino ha inventato
l'ingegneria dei tessuti
poiché l'ingegneria dei tessuti è
l'ambito in cui mi occupo
sono orgogliosa di poter ripresentare
mio nonno ora quanti di voi sanno cos'è
l'ingegneria dei tessuti
vedo la stessa espressione perplessa dei
miei genitori quando prese il dottorato
mio padre si chiedeva come mai avesse
pagato gli studi di biologia e poi
avessi preso un dottorato per diventare
ingegnere mia mamma invece la più
preoccupata per la parola tessuti perché
sapendo per la mia passione di borse e
scarpe credevo volesse mollare la
ricerca per andare a fare fashion moda o
cosa in realtà l'ingegneria dei tessuti
non è niente di tutto questo è quella
branca delle biotecnologie che consente
la ricostruzione in vitro di organi e di
tessuti
ora vi chiederete anche ma perché uno da
ristudiare cercare di costruire in vitro
un organo tessuto per andarla a
impiantare poi in vivo
la risposta è semplice
perché noi
non siamo lucertole ora le lucertole
sappiamo tutti che se perdono la coda la
coda si può ricostruire
era molto velocemente lo sappiamo fin da
piccoli lo sa anche il mio cane team che
è il re dei cacciatori delle lucertole
lui sa che la lucertola non va presa per
la coda perché dopo due giorni si
ripresenta davanti con la coda nuova e
perché noi non possiamo avere la
possibilità di ricostruire un organo
velocemente come la luce art perché le
nostre cellule non crescono velocemente
come le cellule delle lucertole ma le
lucertole oltre ad avere queste cellule
che crescono velocemente hanno anche la
capacità di ricostruire una struttura
che si chiama matrice extracellulare che
ci consente alle cellule di crescere
tridimensionalmente perché noi di comune
con le lucertole che siamo
tridimensionali anche noi e quindi
l'ingegneria dei tessuti studia come far
ricostruire velocemente laboratorio la
matrice extracellulare perché in vivo
non siamo in grado di costruirla così
velocemente
quando abbiamo una ferita o c'è un
ustione anche o dei danni di dimensioni
molto grandi
il nostro corpo ci cerca di ripararlo
velocemente purtroppo non ce la fa
dobbiamo combattere contro i batteri che
sono presenti nell'aria che sono
presenti nella nostra faccia sapete vero
che si appoggiamo un dito sulla guancia
noi andiamo a disturbare miliardi di
batteri che si riproducono fanno tutto
quello che vogliono quindi e non vedono
l'ora di entrare nel nostro corpo perché
siamo caldi abbiamo ossigeno sostanze
nutritive se entrano c infettano abbiamo
la cancrena e lei
l'infezione può farci perdere una parte
di organi quindi l'ingegneria dei
tessuti studia come ricostruire
velocemente questa matrice per poi andar
là ad applicare è una branca
multidisciplinare quindi prevede
l'utilizzo dei biologi biotecnologi
chimici ed ingegneri che combinano i
biomateriali con cellule per poter
riorganizzare ricreare invito un organo
e tessuto che possiamo applicare in vino
quindi siamo riusciti a ricostruire
e ad applicare la pelle impressionati
l'osso la cartilagine la cornea le
valvole cardiache
valvole
cardiovascolari ma ma c'è che siamo
tutti diversi
non è detto che quello che va bene per
un paziente possa andare bene a tutti ed
è da qui che la medicina tradizionale si
sta trasformando da medicina
tradizionale quindi una cura uguale per
tutti in una cura personalizzata quindi
passiamo dalla medicina tradizionale
alla medicina personalizzata ed è in
questo contesto che si inserisce questo
nuovo eccezionale strumento che sono le
stampanti 3d
ora io so che molti di voi le stampanti
3d le erano sempre associate ad altre
applicazioni molto lontane alla medicina
vengono utilizzate stampanti 3d per fare
auto per fare penne per fare case ma di
fatto i principi di una stampante 3d sia
per fare case che per fare un organo è
uguale abbiamo bisogno di un immagine
che vogliamo stampare di una stampante
opportuna e del biomateriale opportuno
quindi biomateriali che prima
utilizzavamo per fare loro la
cartilagine una pelle devono essere
ristudiati ri modificati per poter
essere stampati 3d in base alla forma di
quello che vogliamo andare a sostituire
i medici sappiate sono pieni di immagini
di noi pensiamo solo i dentisti che sono
stati i primi ad utilizzare le stampanti
3d tutte le corone dei denti che ci
vanno rifare ormai non si fanno più con
quella passa che dobbiamo mettere dentro
la bocca ma con la stampa 3d anche il
maxillo facciale che settore della
specialità che ci fa la ricostruzione
della faccia in presenza di grossi
traumi ormai utilizzano le stampanti 3d
pensate ci sono degli scanner facciali
che scannerizzano la faccia o
addirittura una foto del paziente
e l'informazione è in grado di darla
alla stampante per ricostruire l'osso da
ricostruire o gli strumenti che possono
servire al chirurgo per poter
ricostruire un viso ma non solo ci siamo
anche in chirurgia in chirurgia
vascolare questa per esempio è un
aneurisma quella palla che vedete in
mezzo è una dilatazione
mentre vicino
abbiamo un vaso stampato in tre
dimensioni
anche qui so che la domanda come si
diceva nasce spontanea ma perché è un
chirurgo deve avere stampato sulla sua
scrivania un pezzo di organo che deve
stampare è un feticista non ora
quando
noi siamo sottoposti degli interventi
chirurgici intendiamo degli interventi
chirurgici importanti quegli interventi
in cui è previsto che ci aprono come un
pollo arrosto so che adesso il pollo lo
mangerete con uno studio di uno sguardo
un po diverso per poterlo fare
siamo ovviamente in diamo in anestesia
per farlo basta una temperatura ci
arriva meno ossigeno al cervello
in meno ossigeno al cervello e chiaro
che comporta quando ci risvegliamo che
la ripresa è molto più lunga possiamo
avere dei brevi periodi che si chiamano
di delirio perché effettivamente il
nostro cervello deve riprendere le
connessioni che non ha prezzo
mentre i chirurghi operano spesso si
possono trovare davanti alla situazione
molto diversa rispetto a quello che
hanno visto nella foto perché passiamo
da una situazione
bidimensionale una tridimensionale e
quindi con noi li distesi aperti con un
po come un pollo con poco ossigeno loro
tirano sulle varie parti e cercano ora
personalmente preferirei che queste
ricerche le facessero sul pezzo di
plastica ed infatti è stato dimostrato
che quando fanno queste attività che si
chiama blending chirurgico
la durata dell'intervento si riduce del
20 per cento
e i tempi di ripresa del paziente
migliorano del 40 per cento quindi il
clan in chirurgico assolutamente
incrementa e aiuta il chirurgo ma noi
facciamo di più perché una volta che il
chirurgo è riuscito a fare tranne
chirurgico noi siamo riusciti anche a
stampare i nostri amate i materiali con
le cellule quindi abbiamo la fase del
plugin chirurgico il chirurgo sa cosa
deve operare il chirurgo ha il materiale
con le cellule del paziente da
impiantare e poi chirurgo può intentarla
e quindi cosa può inventare tutto l'osso
l'orecchio abbiamo salvato l'orecchio
del grande puffo come avete potuto
vedere qui azzurra
si può stampare la carne è tutta questa
attività che saranno impiantando e può
trattando proprio direttamente i
pazienti chiaramente si è bloccata
durante il comet e dopo i primi mesi di
depressione di tristezza non sapevamo
cosa fare ho incominciato a condividere
i miei progetti di ricerca le mie idee
con i collaboratori
distribuiti in giro per l'europa con le
varie connessioni che avevo ed è durante
queste connessioni che sono emerse un
sacco di nuove opzioni ho conosciuto un
sacco di
capitano uncino che avevano nascosti nel
loro cassetto degli uncini che non
sapevano assolutamente cosa farsene
e questi uncini invece erano degli
strumenti eccezionali per la medicina
rigenerativa
in particolare uno strumento che secondo
me è eccezionale sul quale noi stiamo
facendo tantissime ricerca sono i
sensori
ora voi sensori li conoscerete le avrete
quasi tutta perché sono certa gli
smartwatch che voi avete o tutte quelle
fasce che utilizzate per fare sport non
fanno altro che trasferire segnali
biologici al cellulare e allora perché
non utilizzare questi segnali che poi
sono piccoli come dei chicchi di riso
dentro le protesi che noi andiamo a
costruire abbiamo pensato in particolare
a tutti quei pazienti oncologici che
durante il covip non solo potuti andare
in ospedale a farsi controlli questo
vuol dire per un paziente oncologico una
tragedia perché saltare un anno di
controllo può fare la differenza tra la
vita e la morte
fare quindi delle protesi impiantabili
con questo sensore consente al sensore
di catturare le molecole tumorale che il
tumore che si può ripresentare e va a
produrre in questo caso in questo modo
il paziente sano il suo cellulare
se il tumore si è risvegliato o si è
formato ed al cellulare quindi avrà un
segnale che gli consente di andare
velocemente in ospedale per farsi
controlli e spesso nel tumore prenderlo
nelle prime fasi fa la differenza tra la
vita e la morte
quindi il messaggio che voglio lasciarvi
in questi ultimi minuti è che la ricerca
corre quello che vi sto raccontando oggi
domani è già vecchio e noi non solo due
biologi tutti non abbiamo gli strumenti
per poter correre ed essere sempre
avanti degli altri è difficile
recuperare finanziamenti di grosse
dimensioni e soprattutto le grosse
innovazioni li abbiamo solo condividendo
i risultati con il capitano uncino che
lavorano i progetti molto distanti da
loro ma vicino a noi possono permettere
di fare la differenza quindi il mio
invito è quello sempre di condividere di
non rimanere chiusi dentro e non pensare
che le proprie idee le nostre idee
chiuse nel cassetto da sole possono
prendere il volo solo così possiamo
ricominciare con questo finito e vi
ringrazio per l'attenzione
[Applauso]